all right let's get into audience
questions for the week here's the first
one hey David why do you keep saying
you're Hispanic it seems like obvious BS
please stop saying that so so this is
this is an ongoing thing according to
the United States Census as an immigrant
from Argentina who came to the United
States and learned English when I got
here the US Census Bureau says that I am
indeed Hispanic or Latino Hispanic or
Latino is a person of Cuban Mexican
Puerto Rican Central or South American
descent or other Spanish culture or
origin regardless of race okay so a
Hispanic or Latino person can be of any
race of any ancestry any ethnicity that
speaks Spanish or Portuguese from these
countries that are listed that is me
okay now there's no question that
because my ethnicity is Ashkenazi Jewish
and I moved to the United States young
enough to be speaking English mostly
without an accent except for some random
words that some in the audience are
acquainted with I am NOT ignorant to the
reality that my experience as an adult
in the United States once I learned
English in the United States is
effectively that of a white American
with whatever degree of privilege that
affords me and whatever your belief is
about white privilege that's not what
the argument is about whatever degree
you believe exists and it would be a
little weird to think that there is no
degree of white privilege I understand
that I have that it is conferred to me
by virtue of having come to the United
States early enough to speak English
without an accent and because of the way
I look I'm not identified as Hispanic
but as far as the census is concerned I
am Hispanic and of course I was raised
in Hispanic culture and I still of
course have family in Argentina and
spend time there and identify with all
of the things that are implicit in that
so you know when I talk about on the
show in the context of it the
immigration debate or whatever and I
talked about being Hispanic it's sort of
tongue-in-cheek in the sense that I mean
listen my view is primarily
informed by being you know an an
educated person in the United States who
has empathy and cares about economics
and national security and treating
people with dignity and the reality is
that according to the census being
Hispanic is not the primary lens through
which I am seeing these issues at least
not in a conscious way but it's not BS
and the it's funny there's people in the
audience who think that the idea of me
being Hispanic is BS and there's a
contingent of hatreds in the audience
that regularly attack me in
anti-hispanic ways with the slurs that
you often hear about Central and South
Americans and with go back to you know
Argentina type of stuff
in any case yeah I am Hispanic according
to the census my my culture is a you
know a mix of South American Argentinian
and cultural Judaism and just growing up
in the Northeast and and you know
interestingly enough a lot of my culture
is more a metropolitan city culture than
anything else which is often much more
similar between countries then the
culture often is between rural and urban
areas within the United States but
that's probably a conversation for a
different day